من المؤكد أن القوات الجوية هي إحدى
الأولويات الكبرى بالنسبة للأوكرانيين، فقد تم
استنفادها في العامين الماضيين منذ أن كانت
هذه الحرب مستعرة، ولم يكن لدى الأوكرانيين
بالطبع سوى
طائرات قديمة جدًا كانوا يستخدمونها ضد
الطائرات الروسية الأكثر حداثة، لذا  من المؤكد أن
القوات الجوية تمثل أولوية كبيرة بالنسبة لهم
ليس فقط فيما يتعلق بالطائرات التي
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم بحاجة إليها ولكن أيضًا فيما
يتعلق بالصواريخ التي يريدون
إطلاقها في نفس الوقت الذي
يحتاج فيه الأوكرانيون بشكل أساسي إلى كل شيء آخر بالإضافة إلى
الدبابات والمركبات المدرعة والمدفعية.
القدرة على أن تكون على قدم المساواة مع الروس
في الوقت الحالي، هناك بالتأكيد عجز، وأخيرًا
وليس آخرًا،
يبدو من المهم جدًا بالنسبة للأوكرانيين
أن يجلبوا المزيد من الأشخاص إلى
ساحة المعركة، أحد الأشياء التي
تحدث عنها الأوكرانيون هو
المزيد من التعبئة في  حقيقة
يقول أعلى جنرال في أوكرانيا إنه يحتاج إلى حوالي
نصف مليون جندي إضافي على
الأرض [الموسيقى].